KORY JEFFREY:
Welcome, everybody.
We are on site in San Francisco
at the Founder World event.
And joining me in studio
today is Sequoia Blodgett.
She is the founder
of 7AM and has
an interesting story, actually,
about how that all got started.
SEQUOIA BLODGETT:
Yes, so 7AM got
started literally last year.
So I was working as a
commercial music video
director for seven years
straight, consistently pounding
out projects.
And about May of 2014 I ended
up getting really, really sick,
and I didn't know what it was.
And I went to the hospital,
and doctors came in,
and the neurologist came in.
And then they were
like, you need an MRI.
And I was like, wait,
what is going on?
So eventually,
after 20, 30 tests,
they figured out I had
transverse myelitis, which
is like, you get a common cold.
The cold affects
your spinal cord,
shuts down your
entire nervous system.
Your entire body goes numb.
So now you could see why I
felt like this was it, right?
So as I was in the
hospital, I was reflecting,
and I was like, if
this was it, would I
be excited that all I did was
create pretty amazing visuals?
And I felt like my life had
more purpose and more meaning,
and I just wanted a
bigger fulfillment.
So I decided to move and shift
into the personal development
space, joined Draper University,
and went through the program
to build up the company.
Came in very green, had no
idea what entrepreneurship
was-- like, a scale?
What do you mean, that
thing in the bathroom?
What's that?
So went for the entire
program, committed 130%,
got investment from Tim Draper
at the end of the program,
and started to
build the company.
KORY JEFFREY: Talk
to me a little bit
about that transition
from the video marketing
world to entrepreneurship.
SEQUOIA BLODGETT: It
was really interesting,
because as a director,
you're always pitching.
You're always trying to sell.
So I felt like the transition
was actually normal,
in terms of what it felt
like to be an entrepreneur.
The details were missing.
Yeah, different concept, like,
OK, building the right team,
connecting the players
together, making sure
that you have the support
system, having the network,
having the access, knowing
how to scale a business,
knowing how to create a
minimum viable product--
like just basics that you would
need to be an entrepreneur.
But a lot of it before that was
like a guessing game, and now
I actually had an infrastructure
that Draper University
provided, in order to be
able to build it correctly.
KORY JEFFREY: So 7AM, we
talked a little bit about that.
Can you walk me through exactly
what that is and how it works?
SEQUOIA BLODGETT: Yeah.
So essentially 7AM is
an e-learning platform
for personal development.
So you may go to
school and you may
learn geometry, trigonometry,
and unless that's your space
and that's your focal point,
that's where your career
path is-- you don't need it.
I have not used trig
since 12th grade.
So for me, I felt like
there was more necessity
in learning how to deal
with stress, in mindset
transformation, setting
goals, being accountable
for those goals.
I thought those were
the basis of life
and what you actually do need.
So I essentially created
7AM as that platform
to offer those courses and
teach people how to do that.
KORY JEFFREY: You
see that as filling
a gap complementary to
traditional education
institutions, or competing
directly with it?
SEQUOIA BLODGETT:
Yeah, I definitely
think you need education, right?
So in your career you have
a very specific vertical,
and you need to know the
education behind that.
However, I think that
with 7AM, there's
also very specific
things-- like you'll
hear about entrepreneurs
committing suicide,
and just these really
drastic things,
because you get into this
very pressure-driven society.
You're in a pressure cooker.
You're trying to raise funds.
You're trying to compete with
your competitive landscape.
You're trying to do
all these things,
and you may not know
how to deal with that.
So it can result in
some very tragic things
if you never figure that out.
KORY JEFFREY: So you just
came off of the main stage,
in front of thousands
of people who
are in that pressure cooker,
who are probably embarking
or on that journey and
feeling all that stress.
What was your message
to them today?
SEQUOIA BLODGETT: So
the biggest message,
besides promoting 7AM of
course, was to add value.
So a lot of people
come into relationships
with the intention of
gaining versus giving.
And having a company-- if you're
intention is only to gain,
you're never going to win.
Because that's outdated,
that's archaic--
that type of marketing, that
type of customer acquisition,
doesn't work anymore.
You have to add value
to your customer.
to your investor.
And that means learning
them authentically,
figuring out how you
can contribute to them
versus how do I get a check.
A lot of people I'll
see will meet Tim Draper
and they'll run up to him
and they'll be like, hey,
can I pitch you?
And it's like, he
doesn't even know you.
So get the business card,
exchange information--
Tim will shoot out his
email to the entire world.
He has no cares about that.
But start to build
the relationship.
And then once you've built that
relationship over time-- hey,
I'm working on this project.
I'm working on this business.
Would you be interested
in becoming an investor?
And then you want
to have credibility,
because he's seeing you over
time build your company,
grow it, or whatever
check-ins that you've
been doing with him.
And two, you're not
just another fish
in the sea that's
trying to grab a check.
KORY JEFFREY: That
makes a lot of sense.
So today at this
event you're gonna
see a whole bunch of
different technologies
and a bunch of different booths.
What excites you right
now in the world of tech?
SEQUOIA BLODGETT: So I love
AI, and I love virtual reality.
I love the fact that there's
so much technology that's
now innovating on
such a large level,
and disrupting so
many industries.
And the future just
looks so much brighter.
And it's happening in
every single vertical.
So I'm just really
excited, especially
with artificial
intelligence and what
it has to bring to the markets.
And just overall, especially
virtual reality as well,
I think it's so interesting.
BitCoin is another
very interesting space
to be in, in terms of
the fintech industry.
So I think there's so many
different innovations that
are disrupting these
industries right now,
and the future just
looks so exciting.
KORY JEFFREY: Do you have a
favorite Google technology?
SEQUOIA BLODGETT:
So Google and I
are like this with Google
Apps, because Google
runs my business.
Google Docs,
Hangouts, Calendars,
especially like anything
Google for business-- so Google
email, everything.
We have an account, they
have a lifetime membership
with my credit card.
Take it.
Do what you need to do,
just keep me afloat.
Yeah, so I'm all
about Google apps.
KORY JEFFREY: Well
that is awesome.
Thank you very much
for joining us.
SEQUOIA BLODGETT: No problem.
KORY JEFFREY: Thank you
very much for joining us.
I'm Kory and this on
site at Founder World.
[MUSIC PLAYING]